Japan's new emperor Nara hito
approaching the throne aware of the
history upon which he treads this is
only the third time in a hundred years a
new emperor has taken the chrysanthemum
throne and the first time any has done
so after the previous Emperor abdicated
ceremony and tradition are at least as
important here in Japan as they are in
the UK and this the equivalent of a
coronation was a characteristically
precise and elegant ritual Oh Bonnie I
hereby swear that I will act according
to the constitution and fulfill my
responsibilities as the symbol of the
state and of the unity of the people in
Japan while always praying for their
happiness and the peace of the world I
always stand with the people among the
crowd of visiting dignitaries Prince
Charles perhaps looking on with interest
at a younger Manik taking the place of
an older ruler after they abdicated now
hito was heralded by the representative
of the people japan's Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a giving three shouts of
bands I a wish of 10,000 years of a long
life for the Emperor
tradition and history matters especially
in this part of the world Japan is
currently in a bitter economic conflict
with South Korea because of a historical
dispute over the second world war and
this ancient monarchy is responding to
other current events a parade by the
Emperor has been postponed
while Japan focuses his efforts on
cleaning up the damage of Typhoon
Haggadahs which killed at least 80
people as he is young and energetic
without standing leadership I hope he'll
stay to support the people of Japan
which has faith continuous disasters and
typhoons
now hito is the first emperor to take
over while his predecessor his father
the former emperor akihito is still
alive a new embodiment of the continuity
that defines the imperial families role
in today's japan Tom Cheshire sky news